well the first day of spring is sunday
but there's a place that can get you
in the spring mood before then rocky is
live where you can visit springtime
celebrations from around the world
in one place hey rocky
hey mercedes and jc yeah we're all
wishing we could travel around the world
right now
but you just need to come to the
bellagio because you can do that right
here
at the conservatory we have leslie and
ed here who
create this beautiful place every season
so let's start with ed who is the
conservatory designer now you're taking
us around the world how is that
we are people are not traveling right
now so we brought the world here to the
bellagio
i love it so tell us about each place
because this is about the story as well
as the visuals so we're starting here
behind us in holland
and the kookana flower festival the
cherry blossom festival in washington dc
oh bucket list
soundchrome which is the water festival
in thailand and our big finale piece
here
is the chelsea flower show in england
wow this is so incredible
i know a lot of a lot went into building
this because
right now it's just so important for
everybody to get out and just enjoy
you know something beautiful right you
know these these festivals are not
things that people can go to this
particular the year so we wanted to
bring them here
so everybody can enjoy them and keep up
the momentum people celebrating
beautiful floral creations definitely
and speaking of momentum ed let's move
over to leslie now because
i see a lot of people in here this is a
little different but now that things are
loosening up a little bit
how's it changed inside the conservatory
we are excited to welcome more and more
guests to see the sights
sounds and sense of the conservatory so
we are experiencing an uptick
in visitors which is wonderful they are
welcome to come here we're still doing
our socially distant
walkway so it's still a very intimate
experience
and we have more restaurants open so
that's great okay now i'm curious
as i'm walking around i'm smelling all
these flowers and this is the spring
display so i assume
that there are an amazing amount of
flowers in here especially this season
let's talk about the numbers sure over
the show there will be over 30
000 plants featured right now we are
experiencing the wonderful scent of the
hyacinths that are blooming so we have
dutch bulb plants who have been in the
ground waiting to reveal themselves
all year long amazing so how long can we
enjoy this one
through may 22nd okay everybody bring
your families date night because
one thing i'd like to point out at night
this place completely changes and it
becomes a whole different experience
right ed right and
that leslie and her team have just
installed the amazing state-of-the-art
brand new lighting system
so it's even more spectacular at night
than it has been in the past there you
go
you don't need any more convincing there
so come on down to the conservatory at
the bellagio you guys this is beautiful
and it smells so nice great
instagramable pictures too
so i'll send it back to you that is
truly
breathtaking thank you rocky yeah we
will check back in with you
during the 4 pm newscast